hi there good evening Steve Kaufman here
today I want to talk about writing
correction and I think I've talked about
it before but the subject has come up at
our forum at Linc and so I thought I
would would talk about it I was playing
golf this afternoon and I was thinking
about this whole issue of writing
correction there is increasing
realization the writing correction in
terms of improving the accuracy of the
student is largely ineffective and if
you google writing correction effective
you'll find lots of studies that that
have been done where they study people
who have the writing corrected and even
corrected in four different ways you
know with explanations or without
explanations colored pencils and and it
really doesn't seem to matter correcting
people writing has very little effect on
how accurately they use the language and
certainly that's been my experience
however I think writing correction can
be useful first of all if if I write
something say a link and I submit it for
correction I am gonna take a little more
care and I might look up some
grammatical tables maybe look up a word
in the dictionary to find out if it's
masculine or feminine or how to spell it
or something so the fact that it's going
to be corrected by someone maybe puts a
little more pressure on me and I think
the big part of writing for correction
is actually the fact that we are writing
like writing itself is a very good thing
to do because you're forced to think
think through what you want to say and
perhaps do a little bit of research and
all this time you're thinking about the
words and I think that is 90% of the
advantage of submitting something to be
corrected the actual correction you
receive has
relatively little impact I mean I know
in my own case I get the mistakes back
in fact and this is the second thing the
biggest advantage and I should say the
correcting writing is something that is
done throughout the school system it's a
major part of language instruction and
yet it is essentially quite useless but
what I find useful and first of all when
I was correcting people's English at
link by far the largest category of
mistakes because we had different
categories you know the singular plural
tenses prepositions articles and so
forth the biggest problem people had was
in what we called use of words in other
words it might be grammatically correct
but the biggest issue is they didn't put
the words together in a way that was
natural for the native speaker and when
I get when I got my corrected texts back
what was most interesting to me was how
the native speaker had reorganized the
words to make it sound more natural and
then I would save those phrases to
review so what I was more interested in
because you know getting the cases right
and all this stuff is just gradually
over time reviewing them maybe reading
listening writing slowly you know you'll
get better at it having it corrected for
you has relatively little impact however
seeing you know I put words together in
a certain way and that comes this
natural expression so that to me is very
significant and that's why I think that
writing correction should only be done
by a native speaker because only a
native speaker has a natural field for
how the words are put together and how
the words are used and what is a natural
expression a non-native speaker might
table the correct of tense or correct
you know it's singular or you know the
agreement in French or something that
but those things are essentially minor
and having them corrected he's not going
to have my
impact on you what I think we need to
get out of these the writing production
which which is but I look forward to is
how the words are put together natural
phrasing natural patterns that I can
then save and review and perhaps use so
so therefore writing correction should
be done by native speakers and yet the
overwhelming majority of writing
correction that is done in our schools
and so forth is done by non-native
speakers who will look for things that
they think they know that the student
doesn't know and mark them down on it
which is relatively unhelpful so there
you have it some thoughts on writing
correction I look forward to your views
bye for now